let's face it although 10 years ago
tesla was nothing but a minor company
with a lavish dream nowadays it's
probably the most copied company in the
world and with the announcement of the
cyber truck they've seemed to gather a
mob of companies trying to be tesla
that's greater than ever before so it's
a pretty decent assumption that most of
those knock-offs are going to fail right
well that might not be the case for the
truck we're about to show you because we
think we've found the truck that will
not only compete with the cyber truck
but replace it entirely as the most
advanced ev truck to ever be made so if
you're interested in learning more about
this truck then keep watching till the
end because we're sure by the end you'll
have changed your mind about the cyber
truck the tesla cyber truck was
originally planned all the way back in
2012 when musk announced that he wanted
to create a truck with a special payload
capacity and at the time the idea was
pretty bonkers seeing that the thing
that really held electric vehicles back
was their weight and low power but fast
forward seven years and they seem to
have done it and boy did it look like
it's from the future however as it would
turn out it really was a little too
ahead of its time because as we all know
the truck still has not come to actual
production and well during that time a
lot has changed in the ev world namely
the special and unique nature of the
electric truck has worn off due to the
arrival of alternatives to the cyber
truck and boy there are a lot of them so
let's take a look at a few probably the
most prominent answer to tesla's cyber
truck and their ev dominance in general
has got to be rivien with their more
conventional design easier production
and really solid backing they're on
their way to releasing a few of their
own trucks very very soon and not to
mention the offerings from already
existing companies there's the hummer ev
which will ship in less than two months
and an offering by ford by the name of
lightning which may drop soon too and so
with competition like that it's easy to
brush off any new competition as just
another company but what edison future
the company whose truck we'll be taking
a look at today has done may just push
it beyond any of the competition so now
with the context established let's shift
our focus to the truck we think will
defeat all others founded very recently
in 2020 one might think that such a
young company has no chance of beating a
juggernaut with as much experience as
tesla and normally you'd be right but
see while this brand was established
recently it's actually the conjunction
of two already existing ones first the
california-based phoenix motor cars a
company that you may not know directly
but one that has had a hand in building
evs for over two decades longer even
than tesla and the second company is the
china-based spi energy which has the
funding resources as well as the
expertise of one of the most quickly
electrifying industries in the world so
in a way the company has roots and a
foundation that may just be even better
than tesla just listen to jose paul
placal the company's chief marketing
officer who explained the company's
goals to electric by saying that edison
future is here to provide innovative
bold and sustainable options for
consumers there are other manufacturers
in the truck segment and we applaud
those efforts meaning that the company
is well aware of the difficulties of the
industry and still is confident of their
success not only that but he went on to
say that the ev space is growing at such
a rapid pace so there is opportunity for
numerous oems to address the demand
because our main goal is electric
vehicle adoption we simply provide
additional choices that are unique
stylish and complete with features and
specs that create a unique value
proposition for drivers so what we have
is a company that has expertise
self-awareness and a backing that could
allow it to make something special and
so the only thing left is the actual
physical product that they'll come up
with and that's where the ef-1t comes in
designed by yukona design styling this
truck or well this platform which also
includes the ef-1v a modified van
version of the truck was unveiled during
the latest los angeles auto show
speaking of the car xiaofeng peng
chairman and ceo of spi energy said that
our vision for edison future and phoenix
motor cars is to be leaders in
sustainable transportation with focus on
energy efficiency and innovative design
we are pleased to be collaborating with
icona design to bring this vision to
reality and boy was it one incredible
vision first there was the size up to
243 inches long or over 20 feet since
we're talking about such huge numbers
the truck is longer than any competition
with the cyber truck being listed as
231.7 inches in length and the upcoming
ford f-150 lightning arguably the truck
expected to be up to 232.7 inches long
and what comes with that size well a
three motor setup giving a massive 3 000
pounds of payload capacity a 450 miles
range a 6.5 foot bed in the back and a
state-of-the-art bright orange interior
and that's not all because the truck has
a very special feature up its sleeve by
far the most unique aspect of the truck
is the solar setup on its roof and well
it's retractable shell because as you
see the chinese parent company spi is
actually specialized in creating solar
solutions and so they managed to
retrofit their first truck with solar
panels covering the entire roof as well
as a retractable futuristic shell that
comes out to cover the deck also covered
with those cells the system is made up
of a complicated setup of telescoping
solar louver panels that are able to
extend all the way to the tailgate and
this so-called armadillo armor isn't
just about solar since it also doubles
as a safety cover for items in the bed
according to the team at edison future
they expect that these solar panels
could potentially provide up to 25 to 35
additional miles of range each day as
long as you're in sunny conditions sorry
britain to understand just how
unprecedented this is another ev with
similar design the upcoming fisker ocean
ev is estimated to only be able to
deliver 4 miles a day under sunny
conditions with a maximum best of around
5.5 miles and if that sounds too much
for your budget don't fret because the
company has already revealed plans for
separate models on the same basic
chassis according to edison future they
as of now plan to put out a whole range
based on the ef-1t platform these
include first of all a standard model
the ef-1t this is the cheapest model
with an expected 300 miles of range 470
horsepower and a 7 500 pound towing
capacity and don't think it a slouch
either as the company has promised a 6.5
second launch time from 0 to 60 miles
per hour next up we have the mid-ranger
the ef-1tp premium this time with two
motors this model dials up the range as
well as the power with a promise 380
miles of range and a 690 horsepower max
this guy can bear a load of a whopping 9
000 pounds while also increasing the
launch time by 2 seconds to a fresh 4.5
seconds and finally we have the cream of
the crop the range-topper the ef-1ts
super besides having extra letters in
its name the truck also has a setup of
three motors that make its numbers
borderline deadly starting with a very
impressive 450 miles of range while also
giving a massive 816 horsepower to get a
total of a mind-numbing 11 000 pounds
towing capacity and if those numbers
aren't bonkers enough the truck also
launches at a porsche 911 level of 3.9
seconds that brings us to the final
question now although the company is
confident enough to provide those exact
numbers the fact remains that they also
admit to these models being prototypes
and not the final version and that is
not necessarily a bad thing since the
company seems to welcome feedback in
order to modify their products and as a
result we do not have any price
confirmations as of yet what we do have
however is an estimated date of
production around 2025 and with a cyber
truck having to be pushed to 2023 i
think that's a pretty good window to
release in all in all if the company
ends up being able to deliver on their
promises i don't think anything or
anyone can stand in the way of their
success and well on that note we must
end today's video i hope you enjoyed
watching it and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more with
that take care and i'll see you guys
next time